Jack yes hey man hey so you know there's
this latest Star Talk book that yes
Lindsay Walker and I wrote to in Beyond
yeah she's behind the scenes and all
these recordings of course producer
extraordinaire uh we spend a large part
of a chapter
exploring how empty space actually is
yeah yeah get a sense it's empty because
it's there's the big vast voids and
things all right and but I don't think
people really feel how emotionally
empty they came out wrong no came out
wrong I gonna say space space is just
sitting around just like I I I want to
connect with people I want to I just I
don't understand why I just can't seem
to make that kind of tight fit with
anybody I don't
it's it's it's tough in Spa being
space god it just seems like no matter
how much comes into me I just still feel
so
empty I mean new stars are happening all
the time but still I'm just it just
doesn't do it what do I have to do to
have some sense of accomplishment or
fulfillness in my life I I'm sorry space
your our time is up maybe pick this up
next
week so let's take a look we have eight
planets and they go out you know four or
five billion miles but there's only
eight of them right so clearly that
that's pretty empty right yeah but you
know they're these asteroids right and
most of them are collected in this
flattened Zone yeah between Mars and
Jupiter right okay because it's a
flattened
Zone we call it a belt there are
comets that come into the Sun from all
directions right and if you projected
where they come from it's a spherical
region around the solar system and that
we wouldn't call that a belt because
it's a spherical region we call that a
cloud a cloud right Cloud the or Cloud
Yan ort who's a Dutch astronomer so he
saw how many comets were coming in from
every direction
and and comets are moving fast when
they're near the sun all right and when
they go farther away from the Sun they
move slower and slower and slower so
when he did the when he ran the math on
this before computers by the way he ran
the math he concluded there must be
billions of these comets way out there
in these long Loop orbits that come
around right and they'll spend most of
their time far away from the sun because
that's when they're moving the slowest
okay right Pluto is is the most
significant member of the Kyper belt of
comets right so that's a belt because
it's a flattened flattened disc region
around around the Sun all right 1801 the
first asteroid is discovered and uh
people are excited because they think
it's a planet right they discovered
orbiting in this big gap suspiciously
big gap between Mars and Jupiter people
were saying there's got to let's just
keep looking there's got to be something
there it's a bigger Gap than you think
should be there given the distances
between other planets other planets
exactly so they found series we found a
planet and then they found another one
and then they found another one and
another one the first four asteroids
siries Palace Vesta and
Juno Sirus is the goddess of harvest and
that's the root to the word
serial okay yeah there you go there you
go okay so anyhow once we started
discovering many many many more of these
we realize wait a minute they're all in
the same swath of real estate they don't
sort of own their own space and actually
they're really tiny right they're so
tiny through a telescope they look like
a star stars are so far away you can't
see any size for them these are right
here with us they're right here with so
they look like stars but they're not
Stars right they're
asteroids well how many are there well
we started count hundreds initially then
thousands then tens of thousands
than hundreds of thousands right now
we're up over a million known asteroids
with orbits and and existence in our
solar system right and one of them has
my name on it did I no you didn't know
that I did not you did not know that I'm
serious I did not we've been together a
long time how did I not know how did I
not you have your own asteroids yes I do
yes I do I'm sorry I don't mean to brag
or anything by the there a lot of
asteroids so there there's a limit to
how big your head can get which you get
an asteroid named after you just saying
I don't know about that that's not bad I
mean I wouldn't mind I mean can you see
it now that that's the thing well I
double checked that it's not headed
towards Earth or it's not on an earth
Crossing orbit you don't want to be that
asterid you don't want to be that
asteroid yeah just like Neil Tyson is
coming to kill you
all so it's it's asteroid
13123 Tyson 13123 Tyson yeah that's
that's what it is that's cool man okay
so I have a name wait a minute there now
just very quickly what can anybody get
their own asteroid I mean is or is that
something where like somebody bestowed
this honor upon you it's not one of
those things where it's just like one of
these Services where it's just like you
too can name a
star give it to your girlfriend for
Valentine's Day
star you use the salesman voice right
name a star so um the person who
discovers the asteroid right has the
power to name it after any person place
or thing oh so that's cool so somebody
found this asteroid that you know and
they were just like hey Neil I'm gonna
name this asteroid wow that I'm gonna
say so that's that's an honor it's honor
that's more than an honor that's like
that's like naming a child after
somebody you know okay okay mean
honestly that asteroid is going to be
there long after we're all going your
kid's going to die so if you named your
kid after me it'd be like okay that's an
honor for like what 70 years three scor
and 10 all right it's not like your
kid's gonna live forever you know I was
named after Chuck Nice no but that
asteroid will be there for generations
to come long a serious honor there there
it is okay so that's one of the
asteroids in the asteroid belt okay
there we know of a million there's
probably as many as a billion depends on
how small you you want to count what you
count right all right so now watch that
swath of real
estate is so large
okay you C let's ask the question what
is the average
distance between asteroids okay that's a
very honest question to ask question now
if you if you base It On movies all
right well that that average distance
would be around uh 6 and 1/2 ft that's
right because
you you got to navigate the spaceship to
make it look it doesn't look cool
otherwise right and and and and the
rocks are banging off the side of the
ship and jostling the ship right and
even in Star Trek well captain we're
entering a star an asteroid field and
there they go and so yeah this is this
is Cinematic Trope what's going on as
you enter an asteroid field
okay I got a feeling right now I got a
feeling that you are about to ruin
another
cinematic constant or or or uh uh uh
tradition another cinematic tradition is
about to bite the dust courtesy of Neil
degrass Tyson why you got why you got
bill it like that I just no why you
gotta make me look why you got why you
why you do that something telling me man
okay the average distance between
asteroids in the asteroid belt okay is
about
600,000 miles oh my
God so basically you're like okay so you
can't see it but over there to the left
if we're not careful in about a month we
might hit that
as imagine showing that
[Laughter]
shown that in the movie right that's the
movie that's the new movie version okay
Captain we've entered the asteroid belt
oh my god well what is the potential
damage number one um I don't know how to
say this Captain but uh we can't see any
of them they're too far away they're too
far
away how shall we maneuver the ship
there's no need to I'm I'm actually
going to go take a nap now Captain I'm
going to go lay down
because that's how that's how much
danger an asteroid belt actually poses
you so so what's interesting is our
first Spa we have four well five well
more than that I'm old enough to
remember the first four spaceship to go
beyond Mars in the solar system to reach
the outer planets so if you want to go
to the outer planets you have to cross
the asteroid belt right okay we did this
calculation all right early on Pioneer
10 and 11 twin spacecraft first to first
to have enough energy to leave the solar
system but they're not as famous as
Voyager one and two right all four of
those spacecraft went through the
asteroid belt and nothing happened to
them and if it did NASA would have been
the laughing stock of all spacecraft of
space programs ever because there's
600,000 how could you hit some you can't
if you tried to hit something you
couldn't hit it you got to
[Laughter]
try it's like when my dad took me to
learn how to drive in the parking lot of
the supermarket and the supermarket is
closed and I hit a lamp post any no you
didn't what what what how could
you there's nothing here but lines on
the ground and this one lamp poost and
you hit it how did you hit the lamp post
okay so yeah I'm just trying to get real
here I mean so that's all I'm saying oh
my God yeah yeah that's terrible so
that's why when we don't worry about
crossing the asteroid belt we just send
stuff through it's not even a thing yeah
exactly yeah I mean honestly oh my God
and once again I can say once again Star
Wars has it completely wrong when it
comes to the science of
space star thank you Star Wars for your
cons your assiduous
consistency where you just get it wrong
every
time so anyway that was a long leadup to
that one little bitty fact there you
learned that I have an asteroid I have
an asteroid Nam that was so much fun but
actually and that's the cool the coolest
thing well actually those are two cool
things we learned one you are never
getting hit by asteroid and the asteroid
belt that's number one number one okay
and number two Tyson 321 no it's 13
one23 Tyson one3 one two3 Tyson which
means at the time that was named for me
there was in the tens of thousands of
named asteroids got you okay got you but
now we're like the hundreds of thousands
getting named and so there's asteroids
named after like I said P people places
and things if you discover enough
asteroids you can name one after your
pet um right yeah you so there's an
asteroid somewhere named Fluffy say FL
31123 there's an asteroid uh named Santa
that was kind of cool Santa roid and I
have a friend of mine who obser who was
at a telescope Christmas Day and he made
sure to observe asteroid Santa on
Christmas day oh man just for the grins
of it yeah that's that's a cool thing to
know though once again this has been a
star talk explainer this time how
crowded is the asteroid belt thanks for
being there Chuck a pleasure Neil
degrass Tyson as always keep looking
[Music]
up